à quelques jours de noël plusieurs
québécois se demande si les temps
d'annuler les rassemblements de famille
au genre au jour le jour alors au steak
ce sont votre chez vous ils votent pour
les indécis sont nombreux les optimistes
sont plus rares de report de problèmes
sont tous sont tous vaccinés
on va
mais ici au marché de noël allemand la
majorité des citoyens rencontrés sont
résignés plusieurs ont déjà annulé leur
parti sans attendre l'annoncé de
nouvelles restrictions sanitaires par le
premier ministre françois legault
mercredi ça va être tranquille chez moi
avec ma maman m'a savez tout est là
c'est vraiment toutes les places ont
chamboulé moi je sais que de s'adapter
on trouve ça triste parce que tu auras
c'est pas grave on voit noir nos proches
ces deux jeunes que l'on vive dans le
déni la tristesse ou la résignation le
psychologue marc andré dufour rappelle
qu'il faut accueillir ses émotions au
lieu de les refouler il ya de la colère
et de frustration piments sont comprend
rationnellement même si on sait que
c'est la chose à faire que les services
de santé sont débordés
il explique que plusieurs québécois
risquent d'éprouver le phénomène de
l'impuissance apprise un concept bien
connu en psychologie malgré les règles
sanitaires malgré la vaccination et les
nombreux efforts consentis le virus
revient tout de même en force on part
notre motivation on devient frustrant
parce qu'on se rend compte que peu
importe qu est ce qu on fait peu importe
nos efforts
les résultats sont son polo à long terme
il faut se sortir de cette impuissance
là à se réappropriant un peu le lait la
marge de manoeuvre qu'on a encore dans
notre existence pour essayer de
s'organiser pour avoir un ol qui vaut
quand même avoir hacké port du bon sens
même si c'est pas celui qu'on aurait
espéré car jusqu'à nouvel ordre il est
toujours permis de se voir en plein air
et de rigoler un peu avec les lutins du
père noël ici pascal point lan radio
canada à québec